外道歩いてるサラリーマンのおじさんに突然便で頭殴っドッキリリーロスニョってもう
痛くないピンなおもちゃドッキリ道路さあナンパでてるよ
サラリーマンのちょっとコア目のお子さんを装っていただいて突然ブーブー開かれます
ナチュレを見てるパーカーの人間はどういう反応するんんもうやばいじゃん
雲台ですよねちっ何か食べまーヤバいと思っ
そんなもうありえないこと僕が突然起こしたら人はどういう反応するのか今日はめて
いきたいとおもいます
大丈夫かな殴っても入るこれだ
4つしかないんで慎重にちゃいますね1個はさせちょっと鉄塔としてやって渋滞もたい
死なれると困るんでたようわせいえいいんですね
すぎすげーパントリーと音
見ても物品ですねめっちゃしっかりしてますよもうさすがにちょっと
引き上げがは山で1階ですね殴って見てもらっている
びってもらいさ思いっきりちゃってください
終わっちゃった
ていました
嘘だッ人来ないちょっとリハーサしてから実へ仕掛けてみようと思いますお願います
今度は雨じゃないですか
ここです
ございません
[音楽]
じゃ
バッハああ
俺何したなう
いいんじゃないですかねはい時のリハーサルバッジでございます早速やっていき
ましょうよね
には名前を書いていた
平安盛って食べ
あああああ
t you do
うん
ん
ええええええええええええええええええ
いやー cheer 今日はいえそうねえええ
ん
山様でございます
と重力とっ
いやまぁはなくん
wham
はいというわけでいやあこうやってくるの人にとってピンで殴りかかったらどういう
反応するかでした
ん
うん
ブースてんなぁ
ラン堂前ん
同じ手術するしっ
じゃあ u は彼
[音楽]
次は逆に僕がすらない寒い晩の人に殴られて撮影に行ってみたいと思いますはいこれ
思いっきりぶん殴ったら
逃走してくださいあっ走って逃げた時に周りの人はどうするのでしょうか衰えて動け
なくなる可能性があるんじゃいます目といいよと思いはないん
ん
分
うん
b 0 a
ん
ええええええ
するとおいて形で
あっは
[音楽]
blr